welcome to the show everybody I'm just
going to to say this once
upfront to get it out of the way please
try not to be jealous of my Christmas
sweater yes it does have spider-man on
it and the fact that I have a spider-man
Christmas sweater and you don't is not
my fault
okay the fact that your family didn't
get you one for Christmas just means
that they don't love you that's not my
thing it's not my fault let's just move
on from it I did I do hope you had a
wonderful weekend my weekend involved
our kids coming down with the stomach
bug and if you've never had to deal with
a three-year-old puking well it's it's
not an experience that I would
especially recommend because they're not
very directional with thee I can't get
into details all I'm gonna say is that
if you know like if you were selecting
life experiences from a catalog I would
say definitely skip the puking toddler
package that's just not one it's not
worth it's not really not there's not
much to enjoy I could go into great
depth in detail but what I want instead
of starting with vomit today I think
I'll start with a story that that kind
of makes you want to vomit the media
busied itself
this weekend with slandering some Army
and Navy students claiming that they
were flashing a white power sign on
national television I don't know if you
saw these headlines or not army and navy
students flashing white power this has
been the story of the weekend white
power signs from West Point cadets and
Naval Academy Midshipmen supposedly this
happened during the broadcast of the
Army Navy game Navy 130 107 by the way
here's let me show you the footage of
this of this dark and disturbing
incident parental advisory warning very
very disturbing stuff you're about to
see but but but watch this
four down 40 there so you saw a couple
of kids they're making the okay gesture
the okay gesture is supposedly this
comes to us from the media but it's
supposedly now a white power sign it's
something that the white supremacists do
and so these these and we'll talk in a
little bit about where this actually
comes from this idea that it's white
power to make that symbol and so these
these cadets were trying to but they
were trying to promote white power on TV
that's what the media says now just off
the bat okay before we get into anything
else there should already be some red
flags with this version of the story and
this this is what I always do with with
these media when the meet when the meet
with it with a media hysteria a media
lead hysteria my first thing is you know
putting that aside when you hear this
story there should be like what should
your immediate reaction be you should be
immediately skeptical and in this case
you should be very suspicious of the
media's claims because for one thing
even if there were some racist students
at these schools why would they throw
their education careers and reputations
away forever just for the sake of making
a hand gesture on TV I mean think about
that let's go with the media's version
of the story for a moment these students
are racist white power sympathizers
skinheads Klan members whatever and now
they've decided to basically go on a
suicide mission destroying their lives
in effect in order to make a hand
gesture that that's that's what we think
is happening here and there are multiple
of them doing it so is this some sort of
coordinated thing would they all got
together and said hey let's destroy our
lives by making a white power symbol
it's not like you caught them in the act
it's not like this is secret footage
that was released of these students
flashing the forbidden sign you know
behind closed doors somewhere and
someone god someone got in there and
you know had a hidden camera no it's not
that they did it themselves on TV
because they knew they were on TV
so this was a collective and purposeful
act of career and educational suicide
that's the theory but we don't even need
to get into that because we don't need
to get into the theoretical analysis of
this because we know the media's claims
here are BS because we know or most of
us know the real reason why kids make
that symbol and if you don't know then I
honestly don't know what sort of
childhood you I feel I feel sorry for
you of you if you don't know when you
see someone doing that if you don't
immediately know what they're doing then
I don't know what kind of childhood you
lived I
I really I feel bad for you those of us
who had healthy and normal childhoods
are very familiar with something called
the circle game if you're not familiar
then I'll let Malcolm from malcolm in
the middle' explain it to you sure you
looked wow we're doing this new thing
called the circle game basically then
you can make the other guy look at your
hand when you're doing this below your
waist you get to hit them in the arm
it's stupid but hey you get to hit
people barn doors open brief cameo there
from Walter White I don't know what he
was doing at the dinner table but any
case that's the circle game and that's
it you trick someone into looking at the
circle that you make with your hand and
if they look then you get to punch them
now part of the game as I learned it is
that you have to do the circle but it
asked me like below the waist so you
know if I do it right now then that
doesn't count because it's not you know
because then it's too easy if you could
just go right in someone's face so they
can't look away then then that's too
easy so those kids the cadets you know
you saw the one guy he added above the
way so he was breaking the rules of the
game
the other guy though he had it below the
waist and so that's that's part of the
rule now when I was a kid we played this
game religiously it was every
new the game everybody knew the rules of
the game everybody knew that if you saw
the circle they get you have to be you
have to submit to being punched no
running no pleading no trying to get out
of it no bargaining present your arm for
the punch and it's gonna be a hard punch
to they're gonna they're gonna wind up
they're gonna try to hurt you and that's
just the way it goes I remember I still
remember when I first learned about this
game I was in sixth grade and it was a
baptism by fire it was yeah I had never
heard of it before but I you get to
middle school and that's when you first
start learning about a lot of a lot of
these kinds of things somebody made that
symbol and I looked at I didn't know
what he what they were doing and then
they explained to me very earnestly that
I had looked at the circle and so now I
have to be punched and so I said okay
well if those are the rules then fine
and I got punched and but I was a rookie
so there are a lot of different tricks
that people will pull to get you to look
at the circle and so for that rest that
day I was looking at the circle left and
right and I left bruised and bloodied
could barely lift my arm I got punched
probably 50 times that day I wasn't the
brightest kid as my report cards
attested so I I did come home rather
injured but I learned and I never looked
at the circle again to this day I didn't
even look at that clip I just played for
you which by the way if you did look at
that clip that I played for you then
your otapunch and that's the rule and
that's really what's lost in this whole
thing that those cadets achieved the
ultimate circle game victory they got
they got millions of people to look at
the circle
and so now now you all get now you all
have to be punched you have to go out
and ask the first person you see to
punch you live by the circle game code
we you know this is we when I was a kid
we took it very seriously I'm stunned to
learn that so based on the reaction to
this so many people either didn't play
that game or our pretending they didn't
play it I thought it was ubiquitous
you didn't break the circle gang code
just like you didn't break the code of
shotgun or the code have called it you
know when someone says they call
something oh I call it no matter what it
is if they called it then they get it
that's it if somebody walks by you in
the cafeteria and says I call your
sandwich and you didn't call it yourself
if you didn't when you open you open up
your lunch if you didn't immediately say
I call this that net and somebody walks
by and says I call it then you have to
give him your sandwich they could call
the shirt right off your back that's
just that's the game the call the circle
the shotgun those were the rules you
live by as a kid at least at least I did
more to say about this in a moment but
first a word from Rock Auto you know
chain stores have different price tiers
for profession for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourself holes self
sell furs can't speak do-it-yourselfers
Rock Otto's prices though are the same
for everybody and they are reliably low
that part I can say reliably well
because that's the important part
rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing their
prices based on what the market will
bear basically based on what they think
they can get out of you that they're not
going to do that they're gonna charge
you the least they possibly can in order
to give you a good deal and so that you
can get what you need
rockauto.com is a family business what I
like about it it's an online business
but it's also a family business serving
Auto Parts customers online for 20 years
ago to rockauto.com the shop for shop
for auto with body parts from hundreds
of manufacturers they've got everything
you could need you know engine control
modules brake parts tail lamps motor oil
new carpet for your car whatever you
could possibly need the rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate so you can go there and quickly
find what you're looking for and again
you're gonna get it at the lowest
possible price amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
call will ever need Muraki TOCOM go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right walsh
in there how did you hear about us tab
so that they know that we sent you
that's Rock auto comm you know there's a
whole separate in fascinate
conversation I think we could be had
that could be had hear about why kids
make up all these rules and codes and
traditions and then follow them so
strictly event pain of physical injury I
mean and you consider how kids have a
difficult time following other rules in
code so when I was a kid something as
simple as like my parents instruction
pick up your plate from the table and
bring it to the kitchen when you're done
that was very difficult for me to do and
to remember to do and it felt very
onerous so I had trouble with that but
the rule of if you look at a circle I
get to beat the hell out of you now that
I followed so that's it's interesting
that kids do that but that's a
discussion for a different day the real
issue here is that the media is trying
to pull a Covington on these kids and
slandering them as racist even though
there's no proof that they're racist and
the one thing they call proof of racism
can easily be explained in an innocuous
way and anyone who says well maybe they
didn't mean it as a white power thing
but they had to know that it is a white
power thing and so they shouldn't have
done it for that reason so at a minimum
it's very bad judgment and so on no
that's that's actually not the case
because they they probably have no idea
that it's supposedly a white power
symbol I would have no idea that it's
supposedly a white power so the only
reason that I know that the okay sign is
supposedly associated with white power
white supremacism is because I'm on
Twitter and so I see the media talking
about it on Twitter the only place I've
ever seen the okay sign characterized as
white power the only place I've ever
seen it mentioned or or heard of it in
that context is on Twitter nowhere else
not in the real world not even on other
websites it is specifically a Twitter
thing so the only thing we could take
from this is that these students
probably aren't on Twitter and well it's
not just a Twitter thing it's actually
originally a 4chan thing so this is all
this association that that is supposedly
drawn now between the oak
a sign or the circle game sign and white
supremacism is it's a 4chan hoax and the
crazy thing is that we know it's a
fortune hoax the media knows it
yet they keep running with it anyway
people on 4chan decided that they wanted
to trick the media into thinking that
the okay sign is a white power symbol
and why did they choose the okay sign
randomly as the thing that worked
because it's because it's such an
innocuous normal thing that people do it
is it's it's a it's you know this symbol
has fur has for hundreds of years has
meant
maybe the circle game goat doesn't go
back hundreds of years maybe it does I
don't know but it has for hundreds of
years mint that's okay or you know it
that's it's been it's mint okay for a
very long time and so the people of
4chan just to be trolls just to mess
with us they were gonna take this a
knock you as' thing that people do and
turn it into a white power so they could
have done it with thumbs up and maybe
that'll be next next the people on 4chan
are gonna trick the media into thinking
that if you do this you're expressing
your loyalty to the Nazi Party or
something but we know that it's a 4chan
hoax the media knows that yet they they
run with it anyway and if they see
someone doing it well not someone if
they see a white person doing it on
camera they're gonna accuse that person
of being a white supremacist even though
they know that 4chan invented this it's
um it is the
dumb this thing with the with the the
okay sign it's the dumbest moral panic
in history claiming that anyone who
makes that symbol is a Nazi it is it is
and I I hesitate to say that because
there have been a lot of dumb moral
panics can you think of a dumber one off
the top of your head then now we're
hunting down anyone who makes the okay
sign with their fingers
and calling them suspected white
supremacists well I think to call it
dumb would be to do the media a favor
no it's not it's not dumb it's it's
insidious
it's evil you know they know what
they're doing
try to destroy these kids lives just
just for the sake of it just for a
headline just for politics
really is uh terrible okay now let's
let's check in with Bernie Sanders
speaking of dumb last week it was
announced that Gerrit Cole who's a
baseball star sign a contract with the
Yankees were 324 million dollars which
in case he didn't know is a lot of money
Bernie Sanders never misses an
opportunity to shame rich people you
know anytime there's a headline of
somebody making a lot of money you can
guarantee that Bernie Sanders is gonna
rush in and have something to say about
it even though he's rich himself so
Bernie Sanders sat in one of his three
houses I don't know which one and he
responded to to this news about the 324
million dollars responded to it with
with a tweet saying if pitchers can make
324 million dollars we can pay every
teacher in this country at least $60,000
now this is a bit like saying if oranges
are fruits then Chihuahuas can play
checkers
it's a non sequitur it's taking two
completely separated and unconnected
things and trying to draw a connection
where none exists
if it rains today then George Clooney's
favorite color is red it's it's just
total nonsense but Bernie Sanders does
this a lot when it comes to rich people
king of the non-sequitur if rich people
can buy yachts then why is cereal so
expensive but I do want to focus on this
argument from Bernie if you can call it
an argument because it's exactly the
kind of nonsense that even though it is
nonsense
people find very appealing and it's it's
why he's so popular because people hear
this stupidity and they think it's very
compelling and very convincing so that
for that reason I think it's worth
responding to now obviously the salary
of a baseball player has no connection
to the salary of a teacher because
teachers are paid by the state they're
government employees public school
teachers anyway the taxpayers pay them
athletes are not paid by the taxpayers
they're not public employees so the
reason that teachers aren't paid
millions one of the reasons is that we
couldn't possibly afford to we would be
bankrupted or at least more bankrupted
than we already are but here's the
larger point and that's why these two
things are just completely disconnected
they have nothing to do with each other
but here's the larger point Bernie's
whole shtick is to take an example like
this an example of extreme wealth and
make it seem like an injustice but it's
it's not it's really the exact opposite
of injustice I would say that Gerrit
Cole making 324 million dollars is is
the opposite of injustice it's the
opposite of unfairness and I'll tell you
why because baseball players who make
hundreds of millions of dollars make
that much because they have a highly
marketable skill and they are the best
in the world at performing that skill
the best in the world meaning of all the
people who have tried to develop that
same skill and a lot of people have
these guys these MLB stars they are at
the top of the top of the top of the top
of the very tippy tippy top of all those
people
we're not talking top 1% in skill no if
you're a top 1% you know if you're if
you're among the top 1% of all baseball
players in the world you're not gonna be
in the MLB you're not gonna be good
enough you're talking you're certainly
not gonna be a you know star making 3
ends in 24 million dollars maybe you'll
be on a farm team or something like that
we're talking Gerrit Cole you know these
guys we're talking points the top point
zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of everybody in the world who
plays baseball that's how good they are
okay and we have to keep that in mind
that is how good they are
whenever someone complains about the
money that athletes make you have to
remember how insanely good these people
are at what they do we take it for
granted because we see it on TV we see
it so often that it seemed normal but
it's not these people are again
the very best in the entire world at
performing the skill they are so
ridiculously good that it's hard to wrap
your head around is it an injustice that
somebody who is the best in the world at
a marketable skill can become rich doing
it no I'd say again it's the opposite of
injustice that is the epitome of justice
and it's not just athletes anyone who is
the best in the world at something if
it's a marketable skill and not all
skills are but if it's a marketable
skill I mean most skills are these days
especially I don't know maybe if you're
I mean remember that trend on the
internet which unfortunately went away
because I was a fan of it but the trend
of the the bottle flip game that was
popular back in 2017 or whatever if you
were the best in the world at the bottle
flip game but you just flip a bottle and
it lands back up on it's on the right
side if you're the best in the world at
that probably you couldn't find a
sustained long-term source of income
from being the best although even that
you could you know do some YouTube
videos that goes viral you make make
some money on that so even that is
marketable in some way but if it's a
marketable skill and you're the best at
it you're gonna make money you're gonna
be you know you're barring some some
other thing interfering some tragedy
you know you get sabotage in some way in
your career by somebody else who's
jealous I mean these kind of things can
happen but you're gonna make my baby not
300 million maybe more than 300 million
I mean if you're one of the best in the
world at running a business and that's a
skill and if you're one of the best in
the world and it's well if you're one of
the best innovators in the world if
you're one of the best inventors in the
world you'll probably probably be a
billionaire forget about being a
multi-millionaire so you know that makes
you a billionaire if you're one of the
best baseball players in the world
you'll be a millionaire if you're one of
the best car mechanics in the world one
of the very very best okay if there's
like a few dozen other people that are
as good as you and everyone else is
worse have being a car mechanic you
might not be a millionaire maybe you
will be but you're certainly gonna be
very successful at what you're doing
you're gonna make a very nice living and
if you're one of the best teachers in
the world again you will make a nice
living let's think about this let's say
that you're a math teacher okay well if
you're the Gerrit Cole of math teachers
what would that be
that means that you're one of the very
best math teachers in the entire world
of all the people who do math and you
know professionally or teach math of all
the mathematicians in the world you're
one of the very very best
which means you're both a mathematical
genius and an educational genius
which means you're not teaching algebra
to tenth graders unless you want to now
maybe that's just what you want to do
that's a very noble calling and
certainly an important thing to do and
if maybe you are absolutely brilliant as
a teacher and a mathematician and but
it's sort of as far as you want to go is
teaching high school math at a public
school fine great but then that's your
choice if you're really that good though
and you want to climb the ladder then
you're gonna be what if teaching math at
Princeton making 190,000 to it a
thousand a year around that range or
you're gonna be at some other very
high-level elite cream-of-the-crop
institution
now this is not you know I'm this is not
an insult to public school teachers I'm
not saying that they're bad at what they
do I'm just saying that in in in any of
these realms whether it's teaching math
or science or you know if you're the
very very bet if you are the Gerrit Cole
of that you're probably not at high
school doing it
so this thing that we do where we
compare the salaries of the very best
athletes in the world to the salaries of
sort of you know average people in other
professions is it's just it's silly it's
blatant emotional manipulation
you know there's there's absolutely
nothing we can learn really about
society from the fact that a I school
math teacher makes sixty or seventy
thousand while the very best one of the
very best baseball players in the world
makes three hundred three hundred
million that doesn't tell us anything
about society other then I think it
arguably tells us something good which
is that if you if you're really really
really really really ridiculously
insanely good at something you'll make a
lot of money on it now the when you talk
about this people will say things like
well one thing I never understand is
when someone says well athletes
shouldn't be making all that money you
know yeah they just shouldn't make it
three hundred million dollars they
that's that's wrong they should okay
well who do you want the reason why
Gerrit Cole can make three hundred
million dollars is because we the public
spend a lot
money on merchandise baseball
merchandise I don't you know I'm not a
big baseball fan myself but a lot of
people do we spent we watch it on TV
again I don't know why you would watch
baseball on TV but but but you know I'd
rather watch I mean I think watching
fishing on TV is more entertaining which
I actually will do but which is a sign
that I'm officially entering middle age
but you buy the merch a lot of millions
of people buy the merchandise they watch
it on TV they go to the stadiums to pay
for the tickets and that's where all
this money comes from so there's
billions of dollars floating around
because of people's interest in baseball
now the only question is the money's
there because we're spending it the only
question now is who should get the money
should it all go to the owners when you
complain that Gary Cole makes 300
million who who do you want to keep on
it
so what the owners should keep all of it
or what the government you think the
government should take it it's why the
government should just come in and why
should they get it they didn't do
anything what you think you should get
it no Gary Cole should make the 300
million I should get that I mean yeah
he's dedicated his whole life to
perfecting this craft he's one of the
best in the world
but know that that should come to me
though that's that's mine there's
there's really it someone has to get
that money because it's there for taking
because we're spending it and so it
makes sense for him to get a big chunk
of it I don't see the problem here
I don't again I don't see the injustice
and the other thing that annoys me is
when people when we talk about this and
people say well it's just sports it's so
stupid people you make all that money
throwing a ball how dumb
how stupid well first of all even if it
is dumb and stupid
that's a reflection of us because again
we are spending that money that's how
it's making it but I don't think it is
dumb I think with
most jobs you could do that where you
could describe it in a way that makes it
sound stupid and pointless you could do
that with most not every job okay you
couldn't do that with a heart surgeon it
would be very difficult to describe the
job of a heart surgeon in a way that
makes being a heart surgeon sounds
stupid and pointless so with with some
jobs you can't do that but with most
jobs I think you probably can if you
really want it to you could describe it
in a way that makes it sound uh turley
superfluous and stupid especially if you
work in the business realm if you work
in an office building of any kind
whatever you do I could easily describe
that in a way that makes it sound
worthless even if it isn't I can make it
sound that way so yeah we can do that
with sports because I they just throw a
ball but the only way you know if you're
gonna say that's that being an athlete
the sports are stupid and pointless the
only way you could consistently do that
is if you're also gonna say the same
thing about film about music
okay in film and
these are people just pretending to be
other people what does a musician do you
just make sounds come out of an
instrument what is that who cares about
that so you could definitely do the same
thing what you do with athletics that
reductive kind of view of it
you could do the same thing with the
arts and I think they're very much
related and I think as sports kind of is
it is an art in a certain kind of way
but if you really look at it that way I
mean if you really look at sports as
being worthless and stupid and pointless
and you think the same thing about film
and you think the same thing about music
and you think the same but same thing
about literature even though all these
things can be described that way then
you're not even a human you're like a
robot there's no way that you actually
think that every human I've ever met
finds value in at least some of those
things and not just some value but a lot
of value
that's part of being a human being
unless you're a robot unless you're the
most boring person on the planet where
you really just don't like any of it can
you imagine meeting someone who doesn't
just done like film doesn't like music
doesn't like books doesn't like sport
like what do you do with your free time
what do you like no but as human beings
we do find value in these things and
sometimes it could be a little bit
difficult to describe the value because
it's not as immediately obvious as being
a heart surgeon where yeah you're fixing
someone's heart so they live okay that's
pretty simple straightforward but with
something like art or athletics it's a
little bit more you know it's it's it's
it's a little more abstract a little bit
difficult a little a little bit harder
for us to understand as humans why do we
like this why do we care about it but
the fact is that we do and there is some
deep meaning there
and I mean it's easy enough even with
athletics it's easy enough to see for
one thing you know it's a it's it's it
brings people joy I mean that's no small
thing it took to watch sports you sit
down with your family you watch you
watch sports you know maybe you sat down
to Thanksgiving you watch football it
brings joy to the families it's a
wholesome joy and that's no small thing
I don't see that as I don't see that as
pointless are worthless it's a bonding
opportunity you know it brings families
together it brings communities together
you go to it you go to a stadium you
know you go to a football stadium for
example I like going to the Ravens game
and 70,000 people in the stadium and you
know we all none of us really know each
other very few of us know each other but
at least for those three and a half
hours we're all kind of a community
bonded over maybe something that isn't a
big deal but we're still bonded so it's
in and that there's value in that too so
you can look at it as these athletes
they're very good at what they do in
terms of the ash the actual athletic
skill but they're also very good at
bringing joy to people and giving people
opportunity for bonding that's know
again that's no small thing am I gonna
say it's more important than being a
teacher no I mean I think it also kind
of depends on the teacher
sort of depends on what they're teaching
I showed you know last week I showed you
the flyer of the what was the the flyer
for a a class in what they call it queer
Ecology's at some school in Portland
Portland State I mean certainly being an
athlete is more important than being a
teacher of that class but generally
speaking what teachers do is very very
important of course but the good thing
is if they're the best at doing it
they're gonna you know make a make a
fine living all right before we get to
some emails this is very important this
is actually the most important thing
we'll discuss today and that's because
one of the biggest problems today in my
view is that most people in the country
don't know how to properly cook bacon
and now everyone says they love bacon
right and this has been a an internet
meme for years where people go on and on
about how much they love bacon
yet most of the time I know you've had
this experience you go to someone's
house you stay the night you wake up the
next morning they they make breakfast
they make bacon and then and then you
feel grateful for that but then what
they put in front of you is an
abomination
it's either burnt to a crisp thereby
robbing it of all its bacony flavor or
it's undercooked and flimsy and has the
consistency of microwaved Kaffee or it's
both it's kind of burnt in parts and
then undercooked in other parts and it
becomes this pockmarked leprous
monstrosity so I'm gonna do a PSA for
you guys I want to show you an example
of perfectly cooked bacon I'm going to
show you a picture of what it looks like
this actually is bacon that was cooked
by one of the great chefs of our time
speaking of being one of the best in the
world at something and one of the great
chefs of our time that is me and I want
you to I want to show you this picture
here it is now you see there and please
leave this photo up for a minute
first of all you see only four pieces
and
that could remove all of my credibility
as a chef if I only made four pieces of
bacon because who does that
what sort of deranged lunatic only makes
four pieces of bacon well I will inform
you that I ate three of the pieces
before I took that picture I ate three
of the pieces leaving four to split
among my family and that's four members
of the family so they each got one I got
three actually after I took the picture
I had one more so I got four then they
split the three between them and because
you know that's what generosity is all
about but anyway what you see here is um
I want you to notice this bacon is firm
it's got the nice singe the nice
blackened edge all around it's got the
reddish brown coloring all throughout
each slice it's very consistent the
perfect mix of tender and crispy not
overdone not underdone the fatty parts
are also cooked not burned but cooked
melt in your mouth a brilliant job by me
an amazing job by me now how did I do
this
well I put the bacon on a preheated
skillet heat it to medium-high heat
don't want it too hot don't want it too
cool I put it on let it sit for about
three minutes and then I flip it give it
another couple minutes and now now that
I've done a couple minutes on each side
now I'm really just flipping it back and
forth several more times and and I'm
trying to get that perfect color and
texture it's it's more of an art than a
science cooking bacon that was all about
vigilance it's all about loyalty heroism
you can't leave the stove for any reason
eyes on the bacon at the whole time all
of your senses dialed in sight hearing
smell become one with the bacon tap into
its essence okay you're not just you're
not just doing this visual you also
you're listening you're smelling you're
feeling you're sensing it now what my
wife will do she'll throw bacon on the
stove and then she'll leave because you
know one of the kids fell down the steps
or something and she has to go check to
make sure they'd have to go to the
hospital wrong the kid will be fine
he'll figure it out
it's his fault for falling down the
steps in the first place should have
paid attention stay with the bacon
babies crying kids are screaming doesn't
matter stay focused
remember your priorities remember the
great responsibility that you assumed on
yourself when you open that package of
bacon
you're the one who opened it and now
you're committed you have to see it all
the way through then here's the trick of
course make sure to take the bacon off
of the stove 90 seconds before it's done
so you want to take it off and it's a
little bit underdone the grease is gonna
continue to cook the bacon so you let
the grease finish the job if you take
the bacon off is a big mistake people
make take the bacon off when it looks
perfect you say oh I've got perfect
bacon you want to call all your friends
and family take a picture like I did by
the time everyone gets into the room and
you're taking the picture it's ruined
it's done it's burnt why did that happen
because it kept cooking for 90 seconds
afterward so you want to time it
perfectly
take it off 90 seconds before it's done
and and then you will have perfectly
cooked bacon
there's your bacon lesson for the day
let's go to emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
this is from I'll see you
this is from Adam says thanks for
pointing out the necessity for
conservatives to make moral arguments
but now that you've said that I'm really
eager to hear convincing moral arguments
for conservative stances the two big
ones for me are health care and
immigration why is socialized health
care morally wrong what's so wrong with
people losing private lands and paying
for health care and taxes if it enables
everyone in the country to be taken care
of ask for immigration many
conservatives really do come off as
xenophobes when talking about the issue
it drives me crazy to hear people saying
things like take better care of our
veterans before taking care of refugees
the phrase America first makes it sound
like we elevate ourselves above the rest
of the human family as a Christian I
believe that all people are God's
children as a Christian yourself and a
decent human being how do you morally
argument for the conservative views on
these issues well when it comes to
socialized medicine I think you sort of
skimmed right over the part of people
people losing their private plans but
that to me is a moral problem your take
this people have a private insurance
plan if it's working for them if they
need it
it's something they chose and for the
government to come in and say you can't
have that anymore
we have a plan and you have to go on in
that to me aside from all the practical
problems and I agree with you I mean I
this is what you're responding to this
is the point that I made last week that
when we're talking about something like
health care or immigration or any issue
we have to make the moral argument and
I'm not saying we neglect entirely the
practical argument about about things
like the cost how much it's going to
cost but we have to also make the more
argument I think that should be the
primary argument we make because the
primary argument that the left makes is
moral and so we have to meet them on
that battlefield and respond on that
level it's very important that we do
that and we cannot sound as though we're
admitting that their policy ideas are
more moral but we care more about saving
money because we're a bunch of
sociopaths and Scrooge's but on this I
think that it's pretty straightforward
that that's there's a big moral problem
there with taking something from someone
that
there's that they agreed to that they
need that's working for them and for the
government to say no you have to do this
instead so I I just I see that as
straightforwardly immoral but then the
larger thing with with socialized
medicine the moral problem is is also
the practical problem is that it just
doesn't work it doesn't do what it says
it's going to do which is which is to do
better at taking care of sick people
then then you know then the free market
does with health care and we know it's
not perfect on either end
and we could talk all day about people
who get screwed by their private plans
people who don't get taken care of and
all that kind of stuff and that's a
problem but the the socialized medicine
just does not do what it says it's going
to do
and so you know there are people it the
this this is why you have the long lines
this is why people who are in countries
with socialized medicine will come to
America if they need something like a
heart surgery so this it just does a
better job of taking care of people and
I think that that's both its practical
benefit and also its moral benefit as
for immigration
well again you say take better care of
our veterans before taking care of
refugees that is I don't think that's
our primary argument on immigration but
that is a moral statement and it's true
that our veterans are American citizens
they've fought for the country
and for them to come home and not be
taking well care of that is a moral
atrocity and so I think the point that
conservatives are making on immigration
is that the responsibility of the
government is to take care of its own
people first that's just that is your
responsibilities just like I hesitate to
make this comparison because it doesn't
hold true in a lot of ways but as
parents you know our responsibilities to
take care of our own children first
that's a moral responsibility now the
government is not our parents that's why
I say hesitate to make that that
comparison but the point is just where
do your responsibilities lie first and
the government's first responsibilities
are to maybe I wouldn't say take care of
I I don't really like that that phrase
when we're talking about the government
but their responsibility is to their own
citizens first and there's also this
that if we want to be there for the rest
of the world if we want to be a shining
light to the rest of the world if we
want to be able to accept refugees which
i think is a good thing for us to do if
we want to be a destination for the the
huddled masses the poor the downtrodden
and and so on and so forth I think all
that is great but we we're not going to
be that if we don't maintain our
national identity first we have to be
strong as a nation so that we can then
accept these other people and have them
come in and and and then they can
benefit from it if we become just like
you know if we if we tear down the
borders throw open the doors no more
borders and we become just like the
country surrounding us then we can't
help those people anymore
I think that's also a moral issue but I
think it's good that you're thinking of
it in those terms this is from Stacie
says I want to be a subscriber
unfortunately I have type one
i'ma I have a type one diabetic which
make me get two jobs to pay for but I
hope you personally still read this when
lizzo showed her but Whoopi from The
View said who cares about the kids did
she say that it doesn't surprise me but
I didn't I didn't see that when did this
change who cares about the kids really
this is why it is impossible as a parent
to keep our kids safe I guess that's the
main fight against kids who cares kill
them or make money off of them by
abusing them our future means nothing to
the elite sign mother of five kids from
teen to toddler I didn't see what were
you saying who cares about the kids I'm
not surprised that she said that maybe
I'm a little surprised she said that I'm
not surprised that she has that attitude
and that is the attitude that the left
has that's the attitude the media has
this is what we were talking about all
last week part of it and part of it
anyway
this is what we're up against as parents
that the cultures attitude is who cares
about these kids we're gonna exploit
them kill them in the womb if they if
they escape the gauntlet of the modern
womb then we're going to exploit them
we're gonna corrupt them and this is
what we're up against
and it's not very helpful when you have
non parents who just sit back and say oh
that's all the parents job do a better
job your kids get destroyed and
corrupted by the culture and people who
aren't parents say oh that's all the pay
do a better job your parents it's like
you have no idea you really have no idea
what it's like raising kids in this
culture today even older pimp even
parents who you know are in their 60s
now or 70s had kids that grew up a long
time ago and they had their own
challenges but you really have no idea
what it's like having kids today with
the media being as ubiquitous as it is
with the internet and all these things
this adds a
an enormous extra challenge that yeah we
parents of young kids we have not really
figured out how to deal with perfectly I
don't think there is any perfect way to
deal with it
if you've got the magic solution and let
us know I don't think you do
you might think you do but you don't
thanks for the email Stacey
I think we'll leave it there
an email asking about the issue of
embryo adoption which is very
interesting and I think I'll save that
for tomorrow though because that's a
longer discussion but thanks everyone
for the emails again the email addresses
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com and we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer austin stevens editor donovan
fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Boris Johnson wins big for brexit just
hours after the media say he's down
Nancy Pelosi says the case for
impeachment remains very strong after
dropping the only impeachment charge he
ever had against President Trump and
James Comey insists the IG vindicated
him just days after the IG explicitly
did not vindicate him we will explain
why leftists deny til they die we will
cut through the gas lighting and the web
of lies check it out on the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]